ewan mcgregor has gone on the record
several times over the years to say he
would be delighted to reprise his role
as obi-wan Kenobi if anything came up
but that he didn't know of anything on
the horizon as late as 2017 he was
quoted as saying he hadn't met with
anyone in anyway about a formal return
turns out that was a big fat lie
McGregor successfully bamboozled the
public for a long time as he'd known of
a planned obi-wan kenobe stand alone for
four years he revealed this little-known
fact in an interview with men's journal
just before going on stage at d23 to
make the big announcement of the obi-wan
series according to him for four years
I've been having to lie to people about
it perhaps this shouldn't come as such a
shock though as it's been reported for a
couple of years that Lucasfilm was
attempting to put together a project
about obi-wan technically the official
reports from legitimate sources about
the project have never said Lucasfilm
was in talks with McGregor though rumors
have been swirling for months of course
he'd at least be aware the project
existed after he got as far as picking
up director and Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close filmmaker Stephen
Daldry until now it would have been far
too much of a commitment on Lucas Films
part to announce any ties between
McGregor and a project like this even if
McGregor was only providing advice to a
new obi-wan actor fans would have
flipped their lids even just knowing
that he was working with Lucasfilm at
all
/ McGregor to actually star in an
obi-wan Kenobi project that would have
made the Star Wars loving rumor creating
opinionated public wild so it was wise
of the studio to keep things quiet until
all the plans were locked in place
McGregor secrecy goes deeper than that
however when talking to coming soon
about the obi-wan Kenobi series
production cycle McGregor revealed that
the project was originally pitched as a
single film he shared it wasn't always
going to be a series not initially when
we first started talking about it that
wasn't really in the cards but
everything's changed so much so quickly
it's really exciting that it is now I'm
really into the idea to be able to tell
the story over several hours instead of
just one hit I think it's going to be
quite cool that admission implies that
McGregor has been very aware of the
project since well before Daldry was
attached as director Daldry has since
exited the project with the Mandalorians
Deborah Chow now directing the Disney
Plus obi-wan series can you imagine a
better comeback story
regret
a longtime Star Wars fan got the job of
a lifetime in the late 1990s when he was
cast as the younger obi-wan Kenobi and
Star Wars The Phantom Menace
sadly the legacy of the Star Wars
prequel films has been lackluster at
best but more than a few fans would
argue that McGregor's role was a rare
gem that somewhat redeemed the trilogy
for him to come back to his career
defining role now in a solo production
where he can call the shots as an
executive producer must be a joy from
what we understand now it's clear that
Lucasfilm Disney and specifically
Kathleen Kennedy want McGregor's
creative thoughts on display for a
nostalgia sake it's encouraging right
out of the gate to know that the series
will have creative input from the man
playing the character as of this writing
there's no confirmed information on
plots timeline or additional characters
to be featured on the obi-wan kenobe
series but that almost doesn't matter
right now McGregor is on the cusp of a
fandom homecoming and Star Wars fans
everywhere it can take a ton of solace
from the answer to one question alone
Ewan yes are you going to play obi-wan
Kenobi again yes check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]